afghanistan's girls are distressed many
are in tears a last-minute turnaround by
the taliban on allowing girls to attend
secondary school has left many wondering
about their place in taliban ruled
afghanistan
the taliban sudden reversal means girls
above the sixth grade can't go to school
until further notice
they threw our dreams in the dirt
we are girls and we want to become
doctors or engineers but they don't want
us to study at all
just a few hours earlier these
classrooms were filled with hope
learning again after seven months stuck
at home
but by midday the taliban broke its
promise
a decision that the u.n has called a
major setback for afghan girls
the secretary general says the denial of
education not only violates the equal
rights of women and girls to education
it also jeopardizes the country's future
in view of the tremendous contributions
by afghan women and girls the taliban
education ministry has offered little in
the way of explanation saying
in afghanistan especially in the
villages the mindsets are not ready we
have some cultural restrictions
still school girls came by the thousands
for opening day
a sign that many families do believe
their daughters deserve an education
the islamic emirates says we must live
according to islamic laws
so they need to please open the schools
because it is in the quran that both men
and women are allowed to continue their
education and study
no matter what these girls want for
their future
they must wait for the men in power to
decide if it is possible
and joining me now for more is former mp
and women's rights activist forza kufi
she was the first woman deputy speaker
of afghanistan's parliament and i sat
across the table from the taliban as a
negotiator during talks in doha miss
goofy welcome uh help us make sense of
this
what do you think prompted this sudden
turnaround from the taliban
well it's a very
shocking and complicated
decision i would say
yesterday a lot of people in afghanistan
35 million or so were mourning basically
not only girls who were deprived but i
think everyone who had a heart
and who have a heart was
disappointed with the you know with with
the change of position i would say well
the reasoning is that um that the girls
should be um should go to school within
the principles of islam their uniform
should be according to the afghan
cultural cultural values but from my
perspective these are just um excuses um
their sudden decision to revert their
initial announcement indicates that
there is
a division and the taliban are not
you know making decision on a cohesive
basis and there is no chain of command
um you know people at lower level or
ministerial level have a different
um
level of decision making power people at
the higher level have a decision higher
you know they control basically
everything and the important question is
like who is basically the main
decision-making body within taliban that
is something we have been telling um for
the past ten years that who are we
negotiating who is the one making the
decision and this is obvious in in the
case of
taliban not allowing girls to go to
school despite their previous
announcement is that there is a huge
division and they are divided
uh when you speak of a division does
that also imply that therefore there is
at least one part in the taliban that do
want girls to return to school to
secondary schools
they could have many motives one of the
motives is yes because their own girls
go to school
and i have visited their families i have
met their families their girls their
boys um that they go to school that they
their families mainly for most of the
leadership are not in afghanistan they
are living in different countries their
children attend you know high quality
education um and universities one motif
could be that because their own
family members go to school go to work
and they understand the value of
education the second motif could be that
you know because they want to normalize
sort of their relationship with the
world and the world has been emphasizing
so much on girls education
that it has become a matter of
bargaining for for taliban for some
hardliner it's a matter of you know
taking the girls hostage um
so that the world gave them more and for
some others uh who are so to say pro
girls education it's for them to show
that they have changed that they want to
like have a better relationship with the
world so they have different motive but
whatever motive it is i my understanding
is that there is a division and i call
on those actually through this channel
within taliban who who believe that the
girls should go to school should speak
up should raise their voice
because it's not only a matter of girls
education it's for the future of
afghanistan and if they really claim
that they the afghans they belong to the
territory they need to stand now
i'm just curious um and and i'm sorry
i'm belaboring the point but you have
let's call them the pragmatists whose
children go to school abroad uh some of
them girls and then you have the
heartlanders who don't want afghan girls
to go to schools how do the
pragmatists reconcile uh their children
going to school with the views of the
hardliners within the taliban itself
very soon this fragmentation is going to
go
going to evolve further i think um and
those hardliners either will be
marginalized or they will have the whole
control depending on on the situation
one has to see um but my assumption is
that um there is a fragmentation and
that fragmentation was not obvious
during the time that they were small
group fighting in the mountains it's
going to even you know deepen and deepen
with the fact that they are now they're
fighting over power our resources over
everything over issues so this is going
to even deepen uh over time so if the if
the pragmatists are going to be
marginalized where does this leave
afghanistan's girls and their hopes for
education
um
well i mean afghanistan is the only
country in the world um from the muslim
and non-muslim countries where women are
not allowed to work where girls are not
allowed to school
an education where there is no woman in
public life and that makes the situation
exceptionally disappointing and
exceptionally devastating i would say
and so therefore i think um it's not
even about girls uh hopes which is
important it's not about even about
politics it's about a country because if
there is a group that is so radical that
do not respect the rights of 55 percent
of the society and their policies on the
base of oppression and regression that
means
how could how could they become a
reliable partner for the world how could
they you know ensure that afghanistan
soils are not used once again for
military extremists because the more
repressive they become the more other
military extremist groups try to use
that vacuum and people's unhappiness and
therefore afghanistan can once again
become a safe haven for military
extremists which could threaten the
world's security so it's not even a
matter of politics or social issues it
is a matter of national security and an
economical issue as well
what is the message i mean you have a
huge following lots of people uh follow
you on social media as well what would
you tell an afghan girl now what can you
look forward to
how can what can i say i was devastated
disappointed heartbroken yesterday when
i saw tears coming out of the afghan
girl's um
eyes it was for for them it was tears
for us it was blood coming out of our
heart and our ear eyes so
um i hope as a mother um that the
taliban do not take our girls hostage
they must be ashamed of the way they
govern afghanistan
it's clear that they don't know how to
govern they must open for negotiation to
inclusive government respecting the
diversity of afghanistan allowing our
girls to go to school because
afghanistan cannot live in
marginalization with the rest of the
muslim world look at our neighbors look
at the four muslim countries look at
qatar which was hosting negotiation for
them 15 of the qatari woman or more in
school than the qatari main what islam
taliban are representing i don't
understand this so therefore i think
they have to
be accountable they must feel
responsible and the way they govern it's
not going to be sustainable they must
open for a political dialogue
my party isn't in afghanistan a lot of
my party members are in afghanistan we
are you know preparing for reactions but
we know that it's going to be very
difficult we try to keep the voices
alive but my plea also to international
community will be that they shouldn't
you know think that if everything is
normal discrimination does not know any
border if today we normalize it in
afghanistan tomorrow it can reach our
own borders so they must use their
leverage their financial their
diplomatic leverage over taliban to make
them accountable not only on opening the
schools but also on respecting
afghanistan's diversity inclusion
restoring constitutional order and
moving forward for a prosperous
afghanistan
for zakir we will leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much and a
pleasure to talk to you again
thank you
you